هو بالحدد تعلق من الاوروبي يعني وزير
الخارجيه لابروف اشتكى من انه الغرب انتقل
من الحديث عن الامن الاوروبي بدون روسيا
الى الامن الاوروبي ضد روسيا ما رايك
في اوروبا والمعاهده
القوات المسلحه العديد من الاتفاقات
في عام 2008
[موسيقى]
اوروبا واجراء منها اشياء ستحقق اسامينا
حقيقيا للامن الاوروبيه ولكن رؤساء قالوا
كلا ما لم يكن مستعدين الموافقه على اجزاء
اخرى من اتفاق مثلا عدم توسيعين يتودع
مستعد لتعهدي بذلك وطلب من السياحه
بالقوات العسكريه قليله في بعض المناطق من
الدول التي انضمت الى 97
تهديدا عسكريا
وانا الان تزوده
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن استقلالها وفي مرحله
ما نستطيع ان نعود للحوار مع اسكر
الامن مع روسيا ولكن سيطاب ذلك اولا من ان
توافق العدد استخدام القوه العسكريه
لتغيير رسمي الحدود ويجبرك لديها قبوله
لعلاقات مسالمه مع دول الجوار